my next guest you know him if you're
watching this channel he needs no
introduction please welcome andy richter
hi moses thank you for having me
uh i met we were taping so i'm in the
courtyard of largo um so
but you'll hear some traffic noise here
a lot of traffic
so it's very i feel like the man on the
street the last time we talked
was that the when we were still doing
the show for uh audiences
and you were telling me that on the old
stages you had a place where you could
just go and
disappear have you found a place there
at the largo where you could just
completely disappear
well this courtyard is nice uh
you know it's noisy but it's it's nice
and
uh i i come out here
when conan is doing interviews the zoom
interviews because
uh i just don't want to make no you know
like i'm certainly not going to listen
to the interview
because no it's a speaker phone
conversation yeah he talked to colin
quinn today and like
i heard everything that guy had to say
in 1995
enough with the colin quinn i'm just
kidding do you know there's different
uh races of people in new york and they
came over at different times
no i i love him but but honestly no i
stay out of there just so i don't have
to like worry about
if i get up or you know that the the old
seats in the theater will clank or
something
because when we when i first started
here with them
i was in there for one of them and i
just was like
i'm too clumsy i should be out here just
so i don't interrupt
um but yeah this is but also too like
this place i've known this place
for a million years you know i mean and
i i've known everybody here
for 20 plus years so i'm
i was always very comfortable in this
place even before we started doing the
conan show here
yeah because we people don't know this
is the hub
of essentially old comedy where you can
really work on stuff before it becomes a
special people have taped their specials
there
so it is a cool spot and it's cool you
take it so you
the place that you found to disappear to
is the central courtyard
yes yes although you know what i mean
it's a different thing because i'm not
here
if i need to hide in the hour that i'm
here
i got real problems i shouldn't be on
television if i'm that
uh right if i'm
yeah if i need to hide that much yeah
yeah this is how you got roped into this
show you were just too central
you were outside you were not smoking
and they're like hey there's this
kid that did stand up once
they asked me and then when i found out
what time it was it was like
i might i just just did it here you know
rather than
normally i would be at home uh you know
in my sad dark little box that i live in
uh but here i you know here it's i like
i said i feel like a man on the street
that is something i've noticed i think
people when they do the show for the
first time they're like i hope
conan likes me immediately i was like i
hope
andy doesn't scowl at me
because i think and please tell me if
i'm wrong i feel like you watch stand up
like comedians watch stand up
conan is very gracious of like let's
keep the show on the rails
but you i you feel like you know the
mechanics of it
of like uh-huh yeah that happened sure
on the conan show
you know when conan has said this and
and god bless him he never wanted me to
be any different but
mo uh you know i will sort of laugh as a
conversational lubricant
yeah but most of the time i you know
i i i laugh when i think something's
funny
which i guess is unusual and i
definitely felt
when i went from new york to la and came
out here
and had to go through like the sitcom
process of the table read and then the
rehearsals and everything
where everyone laughs real hard at
everything
over and over and over again yeah yeah
and i just
it's i just feel like you're crying wolf
like you're ultimately going to
[Music]
not be able to tell the difference
between that's really funny and that's
just okay
and i would have other writers say
things to me
uh say things to me like
you know ah you're not a big laugher are
you and i would
i would say well yeah actually when
things are funny
you know things are funny yeah looking
at a math equation
and i'm not trying to be a dick i'm not
trying to be a dick but i just think
wow i'm trying to be honest about
that one part of it and because
i always have felt that the this kind of
job
doing a late night talk show like this
you have to be
yourself you have you can't you know
you're yourself in a sort of
you know like when company's over but
you're
but you got to be yourself if you're
going to be fake laughing fake
reacting it's going to be it's going to
suck
you know and i just also just don't i
don't want to do that
i think that's what i was nervous about
the second time i did the show
because you guys are more front-facing
on stools there you could see
and you know that you know all the
mechanics you know the punchline before
it's
coming you know that yeah you were not
on a bus in australia this morning
and also to be to be fair to the
stand-ups a lot of times
you know it's that's the end of our day
pretty much
and i think you know and so it's kind of
like
it's easy to zone out it sounds really
shitty and it probably is kind of shitty
but
i guess i'm shitty no i think it takes
some of the mystery out of it i think it
makes people less nervous to do the show
to know that yeah everyone's there doing
a job just do your thing
table reads are you brought up are
something else where it is
way too hot of an audience where it
feels like they got
bullied into laughing yes because it's
like network people there so everyone's
like haha that's the joke that i wrote
everyone likes that
have you ever bombed a table read
i have not but i have been involved in
table reads
where someone
gets cocky and thinks oh this is just a
table read so i don't need to
perform at my top abilities here
i can save it or something i don't know
and they get fired
like you can get you can get fired at
any time
and so it's like every time they want to
hear you say a line you better say it
the way you like the money way to say it
yes you better have all the coffee or
whatever drugs
make you funny do that because
yeah it is the it's the second to last
audition
yes and i always cringe when actors will
post the deadline article with a
hollywood reporter like booked it
it's like you are so close to getting
you guys and everyone's gonna be asking
me what happened to that
right right the cw's arrow
that's the same reason that they
recommend that you don't tell people
that you're going to have a baby until
the end of the first trimester
because you might not be having a baby
it's just because it's just
really sad things obviously losing a
human being and a pilot
yeah right up there together in my mind
it's the same there is a table on you
now because essentially every night on
the corner show you are
the only audience member besides the
crew you're really the only one
in the seats what is that like i mean
does it feel like you're
mark ruffalo's character in shutter
island you're just like helping this man
process you have a tv show whatever
trauma you did
process um i mean no it's
i'm just honestly this has just been so
from starting in quarantine
for months and months and months and
then you know and doing the show from
home
and it being completely strange and
you know getting an email and then
shooting a bit myself
getting my own props and being like
doing and i always did it like
immediately when i got the email because
i had nothing else to do
yeah and i'd do the bit and send it off
and then i'd sit there and wait for the
next email where
somebody thought of a bit for me to do
so
coming here was like oh god i get out of
the house
honestly one of the best things about
doing this is that you're around funny
people
and that you get to spend lots of time
with funny people
and in fact you know in your personal
life you can spend all
so much of your day with funny people
and you go home and you
used up all your funny and the people in
your house are like hey
where's the funny guy like oh man i'm
tired of being funny
leave me alone yeah it is hard to talk
to
people that are not in common with the
same way because i think people comedy
say the
meanest things to each other absolutely
like that's like the way
the way that we get to be funny around
here is mostly
mean and i mean and it's it's the kind
of meme that comes from a group of
people that are safe
that feel safe with each other so you
can really
you know you can you can be a jerk and
you can you know and it's
yeah it can be it's so it can be so much
fun and there's such funny stuff
and it's all stuff that could never be
on television just because
it is all cancelable material yes it's
all
either awful awful
you know dark things or it's
about somebody that could sue
i mean it's just yeah it's truly
like one of my favorite things about
doing this for a living it's just to get
around
and they're you know it's people that
are paid to be funny
like they're they're funny yeah which
you know makes the roasting hurt
extra hard yeah yeah they've trained at
this they've been rewarded for it
even from you when you're a baby comedy
baby
you are making fun of each other you are
teasing each other
you know i mean at times it can be a bit
much and it's
it can be more of a young person's game
because you just get older and you're
like
there's enough negativity in the world
you've also
kept up with the podcast you've had
something to do in quarantine that
you're still
able to do yeah yeah i have a podcast
it's not been like
focusing it's been uh it's been nice
and it and it's definitely in the early
days was
sometimes the only conversation that i
would have with another human being
face to face even if it's virtually face
to face
um i mean i'm always talking to my kids
or texting
with my kids but there were like i say
there were days where
you know that podcast i'd record for two
hours just because i was happy to be
talking to somebody
um and i you know i on the i do
just talk to people that i'm interested
in talking to mostly
so there's very little kind of
drudgery kind of interviews it's usually
fun it's somebody that i'm looking
forward to talking to and i'm glad i had
it to do
is there something you're looking
forward to in five years when this is
all
over you it's your life
in five years oh oh i'm always the snow
yeah i mean the way this is going this
is brutal
this is also freaking crazy
and so unique and so unlike anything
that we've ever been through before that
i don't i can't even picture like i
don't i think about
what am i going to do at the other side
of this and i can't even picture it i
just i'm like
i don't even i mean it
it like there's i've had deep
existential moments of like who am i and
what do i do
with my time and
my you know
you know with my emotion and my actions
yeah because other people the way they
react to you and what you put out it
essentially it inadvertently tells you
who you are yeah at least
reinforces the ego or identity and it's
very weird to not have that
hey what do i do yeah i thought i would
do more
i thought this would be different yeah i
mean uh but
it's like down to like am i gonna
i guess i'll still work in show business
but some days it feels like
am i still gonna work in show business
and you know and quite frankly with the
this show ending in june the tbs show
ended in june and
not really knowing what form
the new show will take is it's
it's weird it's you know it's it's
exciting in many ways to have that kind
of
you know sort of change point and those
kind of moments of change
and i've been through them can be great
and you know they're scary but they can
be really fun and good
um but there's just like i don't have
you know the notion of like planning a
vacation
you know like to make sure that you can
get your reservations like
i i i'm not even bothering with anything
like that you know i just because
who knows i just
yeah i'm just sitting here waiting for
it to end and then i'll see where my
life goes
that's what i've seen especially with
the comic con shows you're like this i
didn't know how active you were
in each of the sketches and segments
like no let's just find it out for this
i think that's a lot of people don't see
that work um conan
relies on me because he trusts my taste
and my judgment so a lot of the time i
just get the
is that good yeah or no or
like i said before it needs a new ending
or it needs this joke
or cut that part you just you need
somebody to turn to and go
tell me i'm not wrong um and if you do
it right
you you get somebody who will tell you
when you're wrong which is
a truly beautiful thing about conan
o'brien is that
he's willing to be wrong
he's willing to have to be differed with
um
i mean to a certain extent i can't say
much he may be here
just scream at you after yeah you could
be doing it long enough and still
and still collaborate with people
absolutely yeah i don't
i don't know the best of the room and
there because i'll i'll come up with
stuff that i think is hilarious and then
i find out
you know it's not comedy is not a
it's not a poem you know it's like it's
a democracy
you'll find out that thing you thought
was really hilarious is not that great
and you go oh okay you know yes
hence the need for live audiences yeah
yeah make the meritocracy work
yeah but this is always really great
you're someone that's uh i don't know
it's very helpful to always talk to you
oh thank you
get your input on things it's a good
perspective thank you for having me
thank you for taking the time to do this
we really appreciate it
no problem and um i'll see you around
campus
yeah be around we know where you are
you're at the courtyard that's right
andy richter everyone
all right thank you moses so much